a Monday afternoon at the downtown
Toronto Reference Library
capture video of a man with a knife
making threats any checkpoints secured
in this place police urged the 31 year
old to put down his weapon
[Music]
he faced multiple charges and received a
nine-month sentence
an incident happened four years ago
around the same time verbal and physical
violence in public libraries started to
escalate oh God the first time I was
spat upon was by a regular Patron they
spit right in my face and I mean I was
wearing a mask but disgusting gusting I
have been called horrible names oh you
stupid dumb blonde [__] it really
affects you horribly when you hear that
again and again Cameron Ray and Ayla
mcleish worked as supervisor Librarians
in Toronto they never expected when
training for the profession what they
would be facing
I did have one year where every three
months I was assaulted it was a
Wednesday at 7 30 this guy chased me
around the branch with a pair of uh hair
scissors like you know very pointed like
I'm gonna stab you and that was
terrifying I've seen a person shoot up
in the bathroom I've seen people
harassing other patrons
um I've been called you know hate crime
slurs to my face because I'm trying to
enforce the rules I've come across
overdose victims
um people who are unconscious I did come
across a deceased person once and that
was pretty horrible we opened the door
and there was a young man just sitting
there the guard just kind of tapped him
with his shoe and there was no response
she hoped transferring to another Branch
would help but it only got worse I've
gone through a lot of therapy now and
I've been able to understand a lot
better my reactions and personally I
developed PTSD I went into a state of
complete numbness the trauma forced Ayla
to take sick leave for a year Cameron
has been working from home for close to
two years now
they meet regularly and rely on each
other for support
my whole life had changed outside of
work and I just finally realized that I
was not well one person has been killed
several others injured these problems
are not unique to Toronto at least six
people were stabbed inside and just
outside a local library was the victim
of a fatal stabbing in the downtown
Millennium Library an 18 year old was
hit by gunshots while inside the
Philippe penitone Public Library the
increase in violent incidents in public
libraries is happening right across the
country people are coming to the library
and they have really significant needs
Siobhan Stevenson is a professor at the
University of Toronto's faculty of
information she studies how the role of
public libraries is transforming the
library reflects the larger world around
it there's all kinds of social crises
humanitarian crises in our own cities
you know homelessness opioid epidemic
random acts of violence in places like
just a social safety net that's been so
diminished
[Music]
cuts to Social Services made worse by
the pandemic people with complex needs
often have nowhere to turn for support
libraries in areas that are depressed or
economically stressed where the poor or
unhoused tend to congregate they are
seeing more and more people coming into
their Library you know I've lost a lot
of Staff who have left TPL because they
don't want to deal Cameron and Ayla work
together in the Toronto Reference
Library the largest branch in the system
and the one with the most incidents most
of the time it is someone who has been
chewed up and spit out by society and
they're at the end of their rope I think
there's so much pressure for librarians
to become social workers they want us to
wear a million hats you know we're
security guards now and they also want
us to be social workers putting staff on
edge because they never know what to
expect it's not always individuals
fighting with staff or abusing staff
sometimes it's people with each other
often over computers because a lot of
people living on the street don't have
access to a computer but you know time's
limited so you'll get these fights
public libraries are committed to
keeping their doors open to everyone
even when that becomes more challenging
I would say since 2017 we've probably
seen a tripling of violent incidents
Brian Daly is the Chief Human Resources
officer at the Toronto Public Library
about 20 of our branches have high
numbers of violent or disruptive
incidents late out of our hundred so
that's about 20 percent of those nine
and a half million visits there were
about 300 that involved a violent
incident so it's still a you know tiny
fraction of a percent but having said
that if if you're the person who is
experiencing that incident as a worker
or as a customer of us even one incident
is too many the library is one of the
only places left where everyone is
welcome it's free and there's no
expectation to buy anything individuals
come in here and they come to our
locations because they feel that it's a
safe place that they could they can come
into because of that we need to be able
to provide the services to them here on
site because this is where they come
it's not what library School necessarily
teaches everyone although to be fair
Library schools are more and more
understanding the nature of work in in
public libraries even with training to
de-escalate situations Ayla says the
burden falls on the shoulders of Staff
it becomes this day-to-day constant just
stream of these incidences happening at
the to you or to your colleagues and
some of the things are just this
constant barrage of people screaming at
us yelling at our faces
that's what he'd like to do he loved
going to the library he didn't have to
pay for the Wi-Fi and the library was a
safe comfortable place he liked it there
Tanya calle's son Tyree was a regular
visitor at Winnipeg's Millennium Library
St Barnabas Hospital March 18 1994.
on a Sunday afternoon in December he was
visiting the library when the 28 year
old was stabbed
they showed up at my door at five in the
morning to tell me that my son had been
murdered
four teenagers have been charged in his
death my son was the murder victim
number 51 in Winnipeg but his name was
Tyree and he was a human being and he
was a great human being
Tyree was a unique sort he was a gem
very gifted athlete his whole life lots
of friends in high school he was that
guy that never left anybody out he
included everybody and he carried that
into his adulthood he wanted to make
sure everybody was taken care of didn't
matter if you were a stranger
Tyree was also a rising football star
until a career-ending injury left him
feeling lost struggling with mental
illness and occasionally with
homelessness
[Music]
the library was his Lifeline he used the
computers to stay in touch with friends
and family it was my son that was taken
but it was somebody that loved everybody
you said that this could have happened
anywhere but it did happen in a library
Winnipeg is struggling with youth crime
it's struggling with drugs it there
there's a million and one issues this is
just one of them
in 2019 the Millennium Library brought
in metal detectors to improve safety one
year later they were removed after
Community Advocates argued the measures
kept out the vulnerable clients
when the library reopened one month
after tyree's death there was a metal
detector along with a regular police
presence
these are interim measures until a
security audit is complete
Tanya feels there is no debate when it
comes to safety for those people that do
not work at that Library I don't believe
should even have an opinion on whether a
metal detector is put up or not it is to
keep those people safe I can't even wrap
my head around the trauma that those
people are dealing with right now with
what they had to witness
foreign
she's grateful to the library staff who
comforted her son after the attack my
son didn't have to die alone because
they were there but they also have to
carry this now forever and that Vision I
have a vision of what went on in my own
mind and that's imagination they have
the actual vision of it and to think
that people have the audacity to be
offended by something as simple as a
metal detector
foreign
I want to know that there will be change
[Music]
Jack are you finding what you want when
most people think of their local library
they still picture this a sense of order
quiet and books
but this is the library of today
a place to create
duck into the cave to page
foreign
and even to cook we have a highly active
foodie community
it's a place where you can tap into your
inner rock star and record music
[Music]
[Applause]
or even try out the latest video game
thinking of your community library your
local library as the community's living
room or a third space so it's not work
it's not home it's this other space so
they're becoming a space for the
community to exist in public libraries
are now Community hubs
in Edmonton they've been transformed
into spaces for all kinds of learning we
did the naming ceremony for this
beautiful indigenous space it's
Thunderbird house with a dedicated
indigenous team a space for ceremonies
and Gatherings designed in consultation
with the community so the architect
paneled with white Poplar that's what
all of this is it makes it even more
sacred it becomes a Sacred Space people
who who think that the library is no
longer important are people who haven't
been to a modern Public Library
Sharon day is the executive director of
customer experience for the Edmonton
Public Library I would just ask anybody
who doesn't think of the valuable space
to think about coming and taking a look
and seeing all the services that are
available to to everybody everyone from
families and students to those who have
more complex needs the beautiful thing
about it is that everybody's welcome
here but it's also one of the hard
things about it is everybody's welcome
here
Edmonton library is one of the first to
bring in Outreach workers around 2011 we
recognized that there was a growing
segment of people who needed more
support in different ways that we
weren't providing and that was when we
brought in our first Outreach worker
team providing them those connections
that could be around helping them find
housing supports income supports and
making sure that they get the support
they need do you have access to that no
okay I can help you with that Hillary
Kirkpatrick is one of three social
workers here who have become a vital
resource for the city's most vulnerable
what we do is connect with people who
are customers of the library and connect
them to Social Services that are in the
city of Edmonton
a library is a great place for a social
worker because it's barrier free and
accessible and we're able to really meet
clients where they're at and serve their
needs the Innovative approach earned
them the prestigious library of the Year
award the first time a library outside
the U.S was honored the library can't
fix societal issues that are really
complex but it can be one piece of that
puzzle a puzzle with pieces that are
constantly moving with the rise of the
opioid epidemic some libraries across
the country saw a spike in security
incidents there are always going to be
challenges in your public space dealing
with every kind of person right now some
of the challenges are a little bit more
around maybe the opiate epidemic we saw
99 opiate poisoning Center branches in
2022 which is the biggest difference in
what we were seeing pre-pandemic the
Edmonton Library partnered with
Community organizations they brought in
an opioid response team and added
washroom attendance at some of its most
affected branches their security teams
also closely monitor incidents looking
for patterns if we see that there's
something happening where we're seeing a
trend or optic we put proactive moving
Patrols in those spaces
the Toronto Public Library mapped out
the branches with the most disruptive
incidents in 2021 those are the green
dots they compared those locations with
suspected opioid overdose hot spots in
the city
they tend to be the branches in the
downtown core not exclusively they are
branches that it correlates
significantly to areas with high opioid
use and and opioid opioid deaths so
there's a lot of correlation with with
the kind of challenges we're
experiencing more broadly in society but
the need for services goes much further
the Toronto Public Library like many
others across the country works with
Partners to provide health and housing
information as well as resources for new
Canadians
their English classes are typically
filled to capacity of April 7 8 and 9.
in Winnipeg the social workers have
become part of the library's fabric
they're deeply embedded in the library
and in the community now because they've
been there so long and the work they're
doing is phenomenal
and Toronto is launching its own pilot
programs to help identify and deal with
problems on the floor before they
escalate we're starting to bring in
through Community agencies Social
Service teams these are social workers
these are individuals with mental health
backgrounds who can come in and talk to
individuals who are in distress and Link
them with community service agencies
that are out there
really good the health and safety team
meets regularly with Branch heads I like
the different Partnerships you have
you have resources Brian says the
library is also hiring six new library
safety Specialists who will help patrons
part of their role will be working with
staff to you know debrief on incidents
find out what we can learn from them and
also help support staff in dealing with
often the trauma that they're personally
experiencing by being a witness to or
even a participant in a violent incident
even though libraries are filling gaps
created by cuts to Social Services they
often have to rely on private donations
to fund these programs if they do work
then we'll go to the city and look for
additional funding which is the model
we've used in the past for those kind of
things the measure of success will be in
the end reducing the number of violent
incidents that do occur again
recognizing the number of incidents are
small but when they occur they can be
very significant and difficult for our
staff
so it's pretty intense Librarians Ayla
and Cameron support each other by
sharing their experiences they believe
in what they do and want libraries to
keep adapting and delivering Services
safely I think a part of that is a
little bit of restructuring at the
library and that's adding those social
workers or mental health nurses they
chose the profession to help people it's
so hard when you can't actually help
someone and as much as we would love to
be able to have relationships with all
these people and help them we can't
because I'm trained on Dewey Decimal
Siobhan Stevenson has studied the use of
social workers in public libraries she
believes while programs like this help
they are not the solution it's a much
bigger policy problem my one concern
sometimes is that this can be used to
legitimate further you know dismantling
of programs or legitimating a lack of
funding for other programs oh look
you've got social workers in the library
the role of security guards has also
come under scrutiny especially the
training they receive they're not given
any preparation and they don't have any
of the the trauma-informed training or
social work type training the problem is
guards are abused probably just as much
as we are so they have to take a lot of
abuse and then come back and get abused
some more and a lot of them are
newcomers so they face a lot of racism
and intolerance the Toronto Library
System spends close to three million
dollars a year on security guards it's
now demanding a higher standard of
training this isn't just about having
more security guards it's having people
out there helping individuals in society
to deal with the challenges that they're
facing in a world that's very very
difficult to help deal with these issues
public libraries across the country have
formed a Safety and Security working
group to learn from each other I
certainly hope that all of our staff
feel safe I'm sure there are times when
something happens and it's difficult and
you're going to be questioning what
you're doing in the moment and ensuring
that you've got the sports in place and
so ensuring that they know what they can
do to get the supports they need is
really important I feel that we're doing
the best we can with a very challenging
situation and that this isn't
necessarily something that we can solve
libraries are always looking for new
ways or new partners to help respond to
those ever-changing needs but we pivot
and we make adjustments and refine as we
go and we continue to improve and do the
best we can
to be a really positive response in our
way and fitting within the Mandate of
the public library which is support our
communities and it's that commitment
that keeps Librarians and staff coming
back I really believe in helping
customers and the joy of that I love my
job I love books I love libraries I love
literacy yeah definitely the positivity
of my career keeps me going even though
the library of the future will continue
to evolve and look even more different
than the library of the past everyone
loves their Public Library even if they
don't use it I am really not convinced
that you're going to find public
Librarians there I think you'll find
social workers I think you'll find
public health nurses I think you might
find Recreation people culture people
all kinds of different
professions you're not going to be
building collections anymore you're
going to be building relationships so I
guess it's the new library that doesn't
sound like a library